au départ plutôt discret les opposants
registre des armes d'épaulé hausse le
ton les tireurs et les chasseurs
c'est des personnes normales mais votre
sécurité professionnelle qui qui aiment
leur sport puis que qui veulent pas
qu'on leur impose plus de règles c'est
surtout le le principe que ça amène à
rien ça donne à rien on n'avait pas de
régis s'est incliné de manga fascine se
dessine le mondial sur le plateau ce
gars d'excusés le moule un
mécontentement communiqué aux députés
comme la libérale véronique tremblay
dans chauveau en région la grande des
propriétaires d'armes des pôles est
encore plus fort qui se sentent
victimiser traité un peu comme criminels
qui sont plein temps à ma tâche sont
traités comme des criminels
ceci est un pistolet semi automatique
qui fait partie de la catégorie des
armes et utilisation restreinte
il existe toujours en registre fédéral
pour cette catégorie d'armes registre
qui peut être consultée 24 heures sur 24
par les policiers au québec comme dans
le reste du canada
mais québec veut réinstaurer un registre
provincial des armes comme celle ci les
armes des pôles qui était dans le
registre éliminé par 3 en 2012 c'est un
sujet de forte préoccupation au moment
où on se parle sans être a priori contre
le registre plusieurs députés veulent
qu'on évite d'imposer fardeau
administratif trop lourd pour les
chasseurs il faut idéalement sens auprès
fiasco au plan financier comme été
l'exercice fédéral un registre rappelons
le qui a coûté plus de deux milliards
avant d'être abandonné le gouvernement
estime le coût d'un registre québécois à
17 millions un montant déjà trop élevés
aux yeux de la cac
ces progrès comme ça va passer comme une
lettre à la poste puis les poésies si ça
bouge pas qu'on soit pas compte au final
les chasseurs estiment que les contrôles
actuels suffisent
des renseignements sont déjà recueilli
au moment de l'octroi du permis de
possession et d'acquisition d'armes à
feu des données accessibles aux
policiers québécois
il voit déjà sion 1 pp en interne une
procession d'acquisition d'armes à feu
donc ils savent que la personne peut
être en possession d'armes légales mais
les données ne précise pas combien
d'armes possibles détenteur d'un permis
et parce qu'ils ne sont pas informatisés
elles ne sont pas accessibles le soir et
les fins de semaine ce qui inquiète les
policiers qui en seraient les principaux
utilisateurs de rixes et que nous on n'a
pas bien on n'y a pas vraiment accès
d'un clic informatique
lorsqu'on lit de nuit et qu'on est
appelé à intervenir sur un événement
caractère violeur ou un événement
caractère de détresse psychologique de
jeu les policiers pensent qu'on peut
éviter les erreurs d'ottawa et créer un
registre québécois beaucoup plus simple
les opposants veulent que québec
abandonne et souhaite plutôt qu'on
investisse pour prévenir en santé on
essaie de régler un problème qui est de
santé mentale mais le problème c'est
pour l'homme c'est la santé mentale mais
d'autres pensent que les parlementaires
québécois n'ont plus le choix faut aller
de l'avant d'autant plus que j'aimerais
rappeler mes collègues de l'assemblée
nationale qu'on en est mais à combien de
motion unanime au québec depuis 25 ans
pour la création d'un registre des armes
à feu
malgré les questionnements de bien des
députés philippe couillard a promis de
créer un registre des armes d'épaulé
lors de la dernière campagne électorale
il semble toujours déterminé à aller de
l'avant ici david gentilles radio canada
lévy